welcome to episode 20 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with michelle
romino michelle romino is a canadian
tech
entrepreneur television personality
board director and venture capitalist
she co-founded clearbank a san
francisco-based provider of revenue
sharing solutions to fund new online
businesses
and she made the list of 100 most
powerful women in canada in 2015.
michelle joined the cast of cbc's
dragon's den in season 10
which is like shark tank for all of you
u.s people listening
i wanted to speak with her for a couple
of reasons she works with her partner
so we talked a bit about how you can
navigate work relationships with someone
you're in a romantic relationship with
and i wanted to ask her about her
company clearbank it's a pretty
interesting company
they have an algorithm that judges
startups to see if they're going to be
successful
that means they've managed to take
biases out of judging who should be
funded
by using data science which is really
cool
they invest into companies that look
good after they throw their algorithm at
them
and then loan money in a way that
doesn't involve asking for equity or
credit checks even which is pretty
unusual
so we delved a bit into that and also
talked about how she identifies
companies to invest into on dragonstand
which obviously doesn't use an algorithm
we also touched on how many projects are
reasonable to focus on
at one time and talked about her
experience with mercury poisoning
i hope you enjoyed the episode if you do
please remember to subscribe
shout out to murty creative company for
sponsoring this episode
about a year ago colin murty sent me an
absolutely gorgeous leather journal
that i use at night to spill all my
thoughts onto to avoid using my phone
before bed
there's really something to writing and
writing by hand is therapeutic i find
particularly in times like we're all
experiencing now or times of stress
if you need a gift for someone a
leather-bound journal is something i
think most people would appreciate
and to make it even sweeter for my
listeners colin murty
is offering free personalization on any
of their products
to redeem go to mertycreative.co that's
m-u-r-d-y-creative.co
and use michaela on the cart page for
free name personalization on any of
their products
and that's m-i-k-h-a-i-l-a on the cart
page for free name personalization
for really beautiful leather binders
journals and folios
check out marty creative.co and if
you're a fan of podcasts
go check out their podcast
murtycreative.co podcast where their
founder colin murty talks about the
challenges and triumphs of starting a
small business
so just search mertycreative.co on
youtube
or your favorite podcast app to learn
more so thank you
merty creative co and i do really
appreciate
the journal so enjoy the episode
[Music]
so
welcome to my podcast oh it's great to
be here
i'm really excited to talk to you i
think we should get started
if you could just give a bit of a
background about who you are and then i
will
probe much more deeply into that but
just a brief overview of who you are
sure so i'm a serial entrepreneur i
basically don't know how to do anything
except start companies and that is a
career that involves
an enormous amount of failure and so um
you know i
i grew up in alberta uh like your dad
and um
made it to queen's university for
engineering when i was there i
discovered
worldwide supply of sturgeon caviar was
down by 95
because the world had overfished the
caspian sea which was one thing
but then me and two co-founders were
crazy enough to just like
move to the east coast and build a
fishery from scratch as their first
business which is
everything it sounds like boats
fishermen my hands knee deep and fish
like the whole nine yards
and our thesis was right like chefs
couldn't find the products so we had no
problem selling it
the problem was we went into a giant
recession in 2008 and it was a very bad
time
to be a 21 year old selling the world's
most
unnecessary luxury product so there's
nothing like starting your career with
uh something really not working um
but i ended up uh you know going to work
at a big retailer i saw e-commerce blow
up
i ended up building um mytopia which is
now emerge which is one of the big
e-commerce
companies in canada um built another app
called
snap saves that we sold to groupon it
was in the early ai space in 2014
and then after that a couple of
interesting things happen i think the
first thing
is um i was invited to join the cast
of dragon's den which is shark tank for
all the americans in canada
um and uh and then on a couple public
wards
and it's rare you get like a great idea
from reality television like usually
reality television is pure entertainment
but in this case it was really
interesting because i was seeing
all of these founders give up
huge portions of their company um on the
show it was like okay
for a hundred grand i'll give up 25 of
my company i need to go scale and go buy
facebook and google ads to grow my
e-commerce store
and there was something about like
seeing that pitch for like the
30th time i was like this isn't a good
deal for founders like there should be
cheaper capital than equity especially
when you want to go
um do repeatable growth and
you know on the show i said look let's
like try different deal type instead of
me giving you a hundred thousand dollars
and taking 20
of your company which means that i have
you know some level of control now
and you're never gonna get that equity
back why don't i give you that capital
and just take five percent of your
revenue until you pay me back my money
plus six percent so it wasn't a loan
there was no personal guarantee it
wasn't very expensive capital
and you know that effectively became
what is clear bank
today so we do these revenue share deals
we
help founders with a ton of other things
um but we've invested over a billion
dollars
in 2 800 different companies which is
makes us the biggest e-commerce investor
which has been a really cool
journey a journey that's taken five
years so this did not happen overnight
but that's what i'm doing today wow okay
okay okay i've got a whole bunch of
questions particularly about
clear bank um yeah that's quite a few
things how old are you now
uh i'm there just turned 35
feeling old no no you don't look 35
but anyway clear bank okay how do you
decide
like how do you decide what to invest in
does anything
do businesses have to look a certain way
for you to say
yes this is going to work or no this is
definitely not going to work
so the only way we could get this
big this quickly is by not using humans
to make investing decisions
and that's like totally turning the
model on its head because think about
dragonstone it's all like about the
founder and about the person and
everyone's like
and and i get that for equity
investments that that makes sense in
some cases
but in in this case
it was like why don't we automate what
venture capitalists do so what they do
is they look at your margins
they look at your um you know this thing
called an ltv to calc ratio so what your
customer is worth
versus how much it costs you to find
them and we're like
if we could automate that we would
probably get like pretty good data
so what we what we need our only
criteria is you need to be an online
company
um that's doing more than ten thousand
dollars in monthly revenue so we can
start companies pretty small
and you give us access to your digital
data sources
and then we have these amazing data
scientists on our end that have built
all these algorithms
and then 20 minutes are we're able to
tell you
you know this is how much capital we can
give you and these are the terms of that
capital
and to put that in perspective like
that's so different than the rest of the
industry
like when you raise vc you like go on a
three to six month road show you pitch
your heart out you do 100 meetings you
get
like 95 no's all to raise money and so
this
you know at least we can give you an
option um a lot quicker
and the other thing that's interesting
about using ai to do this is like
everyone's like
so scared of ai they're like we're going
to build in all these biases that we had
in the old world into the new world
i'm like that's kind of [ __ ] like
what we found
is you know we've backed eight times
more women
than a venture capital industry average
not because we've been anything on the
top of the funnel
we've just actually used data to make
these decisions versus like
personal relationships we've backed
founders in all
50 states in america this compares to
the vc
industry average where 80 percent
of venture capital dollars goes into
four states if you can believe it
new york um massachusetts texas
california
and i mean it's this is like no surprise
right like
the vc industry is like male white this
is the crazy stat and
40 of vcs went to harvard or stanford
it's like nothing against those two
schools but like
you're in a pretty limited circle if
those are the only places you're looking
for founders
and you're like wait a second the best
founders didn't always go to like
these insane universities and came from
like really incredible backgrounds like
they actually had like a lot of grit and
perseverance um to be there so
the short answer is we make all these
decisions um based on ai and it's like
showing us these like crazy results that
we never thought were possible
so you managed to get rid of all the
biases associated with
venture capitalism i don't think it's
like all that's a big word i don't think
i think there's always um you know
something that will creep in somewhere
but i think
you know we're showing what people knew
for a long time
is that you don't you don't need to be
from a certain school
or from a certain network to be good at
starting a company
um you need to be good at figuring out
like a product that's like
super unique finding that audience
online um
and figuring out how to like grow and
scale that business and making your
customers love you
so is this only used for people who want
to raise money or
could somebody like me who perhaps wants
to invest in companies
go to clearbank and figure out exactly
how to find people to invest in or
companies to invest in
that's a good question so we right now
um are just for founders that are
looking for capital and looking for like
information like
what their valuation is um and you know
who they could potentially sell their
company to
um but it's really interesting we've
taken on private investors
and uh and that's that would be a very
interesting way to kind of start
changing up the models like
a good idea that's a good idea that's a
good idea i want to use it
that's interesting so clear buying
is something you run with your partner
right
yeah my partner andrew de souza yeah and
he's
he's my my boyfriend as well so we are
like all in
yeah okay um i want to get into that a
bit because i've been
running my dad's brand and there's quite
a bit of business associated
with that with my husband and it's been
really interesting trying to navigate
that because you have a business
relationship and a personal relationship
so i'm wondering how you guys say you
get into a business disagreement where
you see you want to go in separate
directions how do you negotiate that
and how do you do you ever disagree and
one of you
your opinions trumps the other how do
you how do you navigate that question
i want to ask you first like what have
you figured out in running uh
and running the brand with your partner
um i
okay so at the beginning at the
beginning
we'd negotiate and argue and
kind of come to a decision where maybe
one of us would be slightly happier than
the other person so
one would be kind of unhappy and be like
okay fine we'll try it but it's not
going to work
yeah and then we'd go with that and
nothing we ever
did worked out so we've come to the
conclusion that
the only things we go forward on are
ones that make us both happy
because if one of us particularly me if
i'm like yeah i don't think it's gonna
work like
do whatever you want but i'm not really
into it then
it either won't work out or i'll just
make andre's life so miserable that it
won't be worth it
so i think it might more be that so the
only thing like i said that we
go in on our ideas that we're both
really excited about
um but it took a while to figure that
out because sometimes you
think well maybe the other person has a
point even if your gut instinct is this
isn't going to work out
so what do you guys do so first of all i
like to like look at this
this problem like holistically so every
time you fight with a co-founder
it's a miserable fight and it's a
miserable fight whether you're dating
that person or whether you're not dating
that person
i worked for 10 years with two great
guys
and anatoly and ryan still incredibly
incredibly close talked to anders lee
like many times a day we work on so many
projects together
um and when you have a fight it is
terrible because it feels like
visceral it's like how do we bring this
company forward and so
you know i think people get into this
mood where they're like well you
shouldn't work with your partner because
you know you're putting everything at
risk i'm like when co-founders fight
companies fall apart whether you're
dating them or whether you're not dating
them so you have to work with someone if
you're going to be successful like
sole founders are really impressive but
you have to work with people so i think
that that's
yeah maybe the first thing is i always
tell myself like this is miserable but
like michelle you would have just a
different form of misery if it wasn't
this one
um and then i think the benefit of
working with your partner is like
you get to see them in their element
because
we are like our work person is so much
of our personality it's like really fun
to see your partner like
kill it at work um and so i think like
in the back of my mind i have a lot of
gratitude
but when you fight it's a really big
deal so the first thing that i
that i anchor on is that co-founders
fight about everything no matter what
like
if you're not having a conversation
about pricing like every month on how to
price your product
like you're not really co-founders like
one person is in charge of memphis is
not so
i don't like when andrew and i talk
about pricing we i'm just like this is a
normal co-founder fight and i had
10 years of experience being like this
is just a normal part of the journey
this is not
um reflecting our relationship i think
i really liked what you said on like um
we get into these moods sometimes and i
don't know why where it's like i just
want to anchor at a position
to like prove you wrong and i just keep
when i get into those moods i'm like
michelle do not bet against yourself you
can bet against a lot of other people in
this world but don't bet against
yourself
and then it's like
you know forcing i i always found with
andrew and i that we have
we need to have a long enough intense
enough conversation
and we kind of get to like something
better than either of us started at
and if you take that perspective that
like let's
really talk through this let's really
get to the root of this and then we can
get something better
that almost always happens if you're
like we're just gonna get to the point
where one of us is unhappy or one of us
is not unhappy
you're also probably gonna get there too
um
and so that's that's it and then the
last thing is like
i mean we're at almost 250 people like
this company's so big now that we have
enough stuff that's like just different
and so
in in many ways trying to get out of
each other's way and being like i'll
handle this project you handle this
project
um you know really really helps with
doing that but
i'm not going to lie like there's when
you're building a business there is a
lot
of pretty like high-intensity moments
that just happen as a result of things
going wrong
yeah yeah when there's money on the line
it is it is good to be able to
separate out this is a work fight
like this is a work fight and we'll get
through it and we'll negotiate and we'll
like you said come to something better
but it doesn't have to
so i think if you end up working with
your partner you have to be fairly good
at separating it out
being like i'm mad at you maybe until
we've negotiated this out i'm kind of
mad at you
over this work thing but it's a work
thing yeah and
we'll just remember that yeah i think
that is probably like the most important
thing is
is categorizing like um
that and then ultimately like
remembering what you always rely on like
you're super excited about your team
and the project and what you're doing
long term but it's pretty normal to have
work fights
no matter who your co-founder is and so
it's the same if you're just in a
relationship or not
yeah okay okay back to dragon's dead a
bit
um what is the
oh also true local i that that's
somebody
you fi like funded right is that right
yeah so true local um was an equity deal
i did on dragonstone so i met
mark on the show and um then
we also have back then with clearbank so
we've done that we've done both and i
love i love working with mark and uh
as a personal thing i do keto for at
least like two months before i do the
show and so
i'm uh i'm a big proponent of uh
eating meat especially when it's from
local farms so anyway he's got a great
great product and you know him as well
yeah so
just for anyone listening true local
does they connect local farmers
in canada with buyers and they've got
really high quality meat and
he's a good guy so yeah i've been buying
that's i'm in serbia now so that's
different but
that's where i get my meat when i'm in
toronto is from true local
so that's very cool but um dragon's den
what is the
what are some of the good ideas you've
seen what's the worst idea you've seen
on dragon's den
are you allowed to tell me that was
there something like
insane that showed up i mean it is it is
a tv show so i'm sure they do choose
some of the
crazy ones yeah i mean look um
there was this moment on the show where
i'm like oh reality television is like
a bit of a formula and the formula that
captures audiences
is like a third of the things have to be
so amazing you're like
oh my gosh this person came from a small
town and had nothing and they built this
incredible business i'm like
wow um and then there needs to be a
third where you're like
you know like the william hung right
where you're like this is bad
i don't think they realize it's bad it
is really bad
and then the most fascinating part of
the dragon is
actually the third in the middle where
the deals could go either way
because producers are casting these but
they're actually not sure so every once
in a while
you get a deal um i'll give you two
examples like
we got one deal this one time where
like the demo seemed a bit silly and
like we were like is this kind of a mad
scientist is this real it didn't really
seem real
and then we asked a couple more
questions and we're like wait a second
this voice recognition technology might
be better than like
google's is right now and so the whole
pitch
like changed and it was like oh like
this is exactly like what i wanted that
on and
like no one saw the pitch taking that
turn so surprises are really good
um the worst pitch uh
i don't actually know if this one made
it to air but i've never like fully got
over like the gag reflex part of it
which is a guy came in michaela it's a
true story
and he had this idea for giving people a
different type of facelift
but the facelift involved like cutting
your head open
putting like a silicon insert and
the guy was like i'm fully ready to be
the first guinea pig of this and i was
like
please do not do that and i just
remember like
being horrified um what else has
has been but then that's weird that's
weird right like that's yeah
people can come up with some truly very
weird ideas
yeah that's uncomfortable i didn't
realize you'd have somebody
coming to you for funding for a plastic
surgery technique but like
like i guess that makes sense i got
technology for anyway
it was like it was too much um one of
the best deals i've seen
is this company called rvz um rve zy
and it's so cool they came on it was
like an
ex-police officer um an ex-uh
guy from the military that was in
afghanistan and they came on the show
and they're like
you know there is no airbnb for rvs
and in canada there's like 30 million
people there's two million rvs that are
used on average like a week a year
and it's really hard for airbnb to do
this because there's all this like
insurance that basically has to happen
and
they have just crushed it
i mean i think i put in money two years
ago
and they're like i don't know 40 times
the valuation or something like that so
like
just you get these stories that are
amazing and like the guys are just like
such grinders
and like you know we did this this one
thing where we went to boots and hearts
together we like knocked on all the
doors of
people with our views and we're like do
you want to rent your rv when you're not
using it like it was actually like
really fun to be a little bit of a part
of that journey
so i mean i consider like the companies
that i invest in like they become really
good friends
and they you know come to my birthday
party and they um
we just become like a little family and
it's pretty fun to build together
ah that's nice that sounds like fun like
that sounds like a lot of fun
uh before you had clear bank i think i
asked this already i'm gonna re-ask it
because i didn't get enough information
out of you
but before you started clear bank and
you had this didn't have this ai
technology
how do you know what to invest in is it
like a gut instinct or do you just think
about it logically
like are there signs are there signs
um so
my number one sign is
if you're doing equity investing like
before before clear bank before we
we could do a bunch of this um ai stuff
if you're doing an equity deal which is
like
taking a piece of a company and really
trying to help a founder build
um you're really not just capital it's
the best sign i've found so far is like
entrepreneurs that have this like
natural grit and perseverance to them
and michaela i found that this like
comes in so many different
forms because it's like it's like
sometimes it's like
the person that just has the chip on
their shoulder because like
they want to prove their parents wrong
or sometimes it's people that have like
very few other options where they're
like i need to make this work like i
don't i don't get to take a zero on this
deal
but this is a career where you are
punched in the face
every day for like a better word like
most things don't work like eighty
percent everyone's like oh you're a
successful entrepreneur like
[ __ ] 80 percent of the deals i've done
and the the
things that i've tried haven't worked
and so it's really fun when you get to
do the like two-minute bio and i get to
talk about like
the hit list of the five things that did
work but
in that journey was like i mean we built
a competitor to uber eats that didn't
work can make the unit economics work we
built a giant piece of software
um first for small business scheduling
couldn't make that business work we
built like
a beauty box subscription box that
didn't work like i have seen
so many ideas that i have tried put my
heart into and not work
and so that's a little bit of the part
of dragon zone it's always a little bit
deceiving right
we talk about the show and we're like
how big is your market and how good is
your pricing and like
is this the product but really
i'm like watching the entrepreneurs ask
the question and i'm like
are they gonna get up the fifth time
they were punched on this
like that's really what it is like are
they gonna have the wherewithal to be
like
okay that last iteration didn't work
i need to try again i need to take the
like 10 of things i learned from what
just failed
and need to keep going and the craziest
part about
looking for this kind of like grit
hustle perseverance gene
is that it's plated in reverse and so
there's been a couple of founders that
i've backed
that effectively got lucky
their first shot like they were really
young they came up with a really amazing
idea it
um one of them i remember like if she
shot a video on her iphone it went viral
and those are the founders
that often fail later because they can't
see that like
this journey is like things mostly not
working
and being okay with um
with things mostly not working and so
that that's been that's kind of how i
learned to invest
and then probably the other thing that i
would tack on to that
is like can technology help you scale
this business
right because if you're selling like you
know widgets out of a store or building
brick and mortar
like i think of a this way i'm like
imagine you started coca-cola and now
you like have to take coca-cola to like
it's second country right
it's like oh you have to go from the u.s
like mexico that would have been like
i don't know a four-year process and
then like another country would have
been a four-year process and
great 60 years later you have this like
global company that sells your product
but like wow that was difficult
and i remember when whatsapp was sold um
for that like insane amount and thinking
that it was like
17 engineers when they sold to facebook
and it reached
a billion people so you're like
oh my god that that is like the
scalability of technology like there was
no like
putting a person on the ground in mexico
getting like a distribution chain like
getting like all of this thing and so
you like i think about that a lot is
like those are going to be the
businesses and
and basically every company today is
going to become a technology company and
so
where is that layer where you have like
a really
gritty founder that you can
scale something that they're building um
and you can see it right like this
podcast is gonna be reached with like
people around the world right i mean 20
years ago it would have been like we
would have been talking
you know on a radio show to like a few
people
in our neighborhood um and
you know figuring out that that power
and how to use that is
is really cool so you invest in people
yeah
yeah when i do equity deals it's really
like a people thing
um and with that it's like and this is
why the venture model is in some way so
broken because when you take a piece of
the company
the model works where you only need of
10 companies you only need
one or two to be really successful and
you can leave the rest behind
which i never liked like i always was
like everyone deserves even if these
businesses are not going to be a billion
dollar business
it's like when did we get to the point
where we're like oh a 20 million dollar
business isn't big enough for a 50
million dollar business isn't big enough
like that's crazy
but that's the cycle that that vc
perpetuated a little bit
is that we could only back things that
could be 10x um
the size yeah um so clearbank gets rid
of that that is such a brilliant idea
i mean look the other thing is like
it seems like a brilliant idea today
because it's working
but when we started this
in 2015 we had to raise all this capital
to like give to these founders and so
i did 300 meetings on wall street
and i basically got 299
notes i think the rudest one is like
miss
you don't understand credit like
everyone was like you can't do this
you're effectively giving
like small businesses startups capital
with no personal guarantee which means
we had no rights to their personal
assets or their business assets we just
basically said if they make revenue
you've got to share this
this little rev share with us and i
remember i kept saying
you know look if we if we really
understand the data of these businesses
we are going to be
more successful than you know basically
taking someone's house and then trying
to like
get the money from that um
and no one believed us and it's working
now so you get those moments where it's
like
it it feels brilliant today but at the
time i can tell you a lot of people told
me
uh we were being completely stupid so
yeah well they probably didn't
understand ai and the amount of data you
can collect and analyze that way
i guess something like that yeah
um okay what does your you're insanely
successful and you've been a hard worker
obviously for probably your whole life
do you ever
stop working and the fact that you
are a co-founder with your boyfriend
boyfriend right yeah um do you guys ever
stop working and does the fact that you
work together mean
some of your off time turns into work
time so i look at this like
cycle of like working on work a little
bit differently
i think we like got ourselves like in a
really weird place when we like talked
about like
work-life balance as if every day should
have like eight hours of work
eight hours of free time and like eight
hours of sleep like
i kind of knew from a pretty young age
like i would never have that formula
so i think about if i want to get like i
think about a set of yearly goals
and i'm like okay if i need to get the
set of yearly goals done
probably there's going to be four times
a year where i'm going to need to do
like a
really intense sprint like it's just
going to be like
all work all the time and this is like
anything like
pretty awesome that's happened has
always looked like this like you just
like you're closing a deal you like work
around the clock until it's done
or you're like closing a big partnership
or you're like launching a new product
right
um and so i'm like okay when we're in
like sprint mode
and then when you're not in sprint mode
you have to let your body rest like it
isn't one of these things where like
i'm working hard for like the sake of
like posting it on instagram like that's
the dumbest reason to work hard and
people do that right they get
they get this glorified idea that you
should be working all the time like
you know when you're not in sprint mode
you should be like making sure you're
getting enough sleep and like
exercising and doing all the things that
your body needs
um to really function and so i think
about it that way it's like i look at
the end of the year and so then
you're right there are moments where
like andrew and i just feel like we're
working and we're like we'll get through
this like
chapter and then it's like we'll go on a
great vacation i mean
i don't know we went to spain last year
for 10 days and i feel like we talked
about work
like twice or like almost nothing like
and the work that we talked about was
like
brainstorming or fun or like what if we
did this what if we did this like
that's fun work like terrible work is
like crisis management
like this is blowing up and how do i fix
it um
i think the other thing you gotta like
get yourself trained as an entrepreneur
is i always say like every week two
things are gonna
blow up i'm gonna have no idea what
those two things are but i'm just gonna
have to like stop everything
fix the problem and then go back to
whatever i was doing and
as soon as i became okay with like
knowing i mean when we used to fly it
was like okay
you know i might have to like get on a
plane to new york in the middle of the
day
solve a problem i'm like okay that
doesn't feel as bad when it happens
because i'm kind of like
weirdly expecting it um but you do have
to like
you do have to take breaks andre and i
haven't really had that problem we like
when nothing's blowing up at work we
just like don't talk about work
it's like we can kind of like live our
lives and remember that this isn't like
the whole part of us
um but i always find these are this is
crazy the other huge advantage of
working with your partner
is that your cycles are the same so like
i always think about that discussion
people have when they're at dinner and
they're like you please get off your
phone and you're like no
like this is so urgent like i can't get
off my phone but
when you're dealing with the same
company it's like well you got to be on
your phone and if you deal with it i
don't have to deal with it so i'm going
to shut the [ __ ] up
let's just solve this problem
um and be really grateful that i don't
have to solve it because it's
one of us and so your stress cycles are
actually the same you have problems at
the same time and then you have down
time at the same time and so
in many ways that makes it like super
efficient to be running kind of the same
company and being a couple
yeah that's a really good point actually
you that that's
that's a very good point uh you
mentioned earlier that you did you do
keto diet before you do a season of
dragon's den
yeah so what's the background there and
how did you get into that and what
effects have you seen the keto diet have
for you oh that's a good that's a good
question and i don't this is fun because
i don't think anyone ever asked me about
my diet
um it's like half of what i do so yeah
diet questions
i'm interested though because you talk
to a lot of people who are
extremely successful they have something
diet they have some diet trick
and i don't think people don't talk
about it a lot and it can be a really
effective way to
get sharper so what do you do what have
you seen
it's really it's really interesting so i
got
introduced to keto before it was called
keto and it was called
atkins and my parents would do it and so
so literally i like knew about this when
i was like seven years old and like they
weren't you know what i mean like they
weren't crazy i don't think keto
long-term is good for you because i just
think you need fruit and fiber and like
a few other things that are like
helpful if your body can handle them um
but like totally and i totally get your
body snapped
at the end no it's like
i i and i think um
you know all of our bodies are so easy
so that's how i got introduced to it and
i find generally like
low carb just is really helpful for my
own like
mental clarity um and then i find like
it is the most effective weight loss
thing like
you know what i mean i'm just like
anyone else i've probably tried
everything over the years and there's
just nothing that like
keeps you full and your brain
functioning like pure protein
um that usually comes from meat and so
i do it before i film um i think when
you're on a tv show no matter what you
are
way more self-critical of how you look
it's just the reality of seeing your
god from every angle too it's not just
like instagram
yeah in hd without a filter like okay
um and so i'm not crazy about it i
really try and um
i really try and focus on like you know
being healthy making sure i'm working
out and i've done
i've done a much better job of that in
the last like you know four years
uh than i was previously i think i was
just kind of like a bit of a workaholic
before and then i realized like no this
really does matter
um but i just find it super helpful and
then
there's something about
weirdly for me about like the discipline
of dieting where i'm like okay i can't
eat carbs today that
allows me to be more disciplined with
other areas it's really interesting how
like mentally that works as well
yeah that's interesting i think i've
have i found that
i mean i have to go to all meat and that
requires an incredible amount of
actually it's surprising i was like in
in a lucky sort of way i was kind of
forced into it so it took less
discipline because it was like
the consequences of not doing it were so
severe that there wasn't really an
option
the other thing that i've done and and
this is actually really important for
anyone who does meat or fish or keto
is um last year it was really scary i
started getting like these tremors in my
hands like i couldn't hold my hand
oh my god that is scary it was super
scary and i was like what is happening
to me
um and i do public speaking so then when
your hands shake your whole
body starts to feel anxiety it was
terrible and this
really smart um nurse practitioner
actually
was like let's just test your mercury
and
my mercury levels so just we're at
normal range is like 0 to 18
i was at 50 and you die at 100 so like
i had really elevated levels of
mercury and so um it was kind of one of
those things where i'm like okay
you know you kind of go crazy and you're
like is this my water is this this yeah
and i thought it was only eating fish
like a couple of times a week but i was
probably eating way too much tuna and
all the big fish you can do a quick
google search of what what this is
um but tuna is can be very high in
mercury and mercury can make you
incredibly sick and it was one of those
things where it's exactly what you just
talked about it was like
now i see tuna and i'm like that is
poison you cannot put that in your body
and so it was not like
yeah oh i can just have a bite or i can
see how it tastes or like i can miss it
it was like
michelle you cannot eat that um and in
some ways that made it a lot easier
than you know thinking that this could
be like a cheat food at some point right
it was just like
it's just like not for your body
michelle you can't have that and i would
encourage everyone to get their mercury
tested if they're eating uh more fish
because
uh it's just it's like crazy um
how sick you can get from it and just
not even know oh yeah mercury poisoning
that's no joke and tremors
that's terrifying i uh i know somebody
who so
i know a whole bunch of people across
dietary spectrums who and once you get
to something like an all meat diet
those people or i guess us people try
really weird things because once you
realize you can survive off of only
eating one food you're like
well that's weird i wonder if it's only
you know fish
so i know somebody who who he was all
meat for a number of years and was like
well
maybe you could do it with all fish and
he said
he ate only fish for a week and he
started turning blue
that was and was like okay then
probably not a good idea i guess all
fish isn't for me but
yeah tuna how much tuna were you eating
i don't
see the biggest thing is it's like i
thought i was only eating
fish maybe three or four times a week
because there had been so much debate
about less meat and more fish and so
it's like yeah
you know you're like you're just like oh
my god i can't win no matter what right
yeah
um but fish you have to be you have to
be really careful with the other thing
is that it's impossible to know because
i could have also eaten a couple fish
that were
super hot like a couple of tuna that
were really high
anyway i'm just generally like it's it's
um google kind of the list of mercury
concentrations of fish basically
fish that eat other fish um like shark
would be like the highest of the list
because
the mercury builds up so anything that's
small um
salmon's actually pretty low shellfish
is pretty low so there's still a lot of
like things you can get
sardines are good fish sardines like
yeah small fish are amazing anchovies
um but yeah i just i now think a lot
about that because
it was a terrifying experience and like
the other things that can give you
tremors are much scarier
than having mercury poisoning and being
able to get rid of it
yeah so how long did it take for your
mercury levels to go down
um it took
six months um and then it was like
getting back to normal range um and now
i'm in the middle
of like what normal range is and and so
it took
it took six months the tremors probably
took like three or four months to go
away
which was probably like the scariest
part and they would be kind of
like off and on um but
it's like it's crazy you can you can do
it with blood tests so it's like really
something pretty easy to just ask your
doctor for
yeah there are also certain tuna that
are less likely to have
that high high mercury levels i don't
remember if it's skip jack or something
i was really paranoid about tuna for a
while
um because of that but that's pretty
scary
that's that's yeah you're lucky you
found somebody smart like that's not
i i would assume mercury poisoning isn't
something that
people would normally be picked up i i
think you're right it is not
normally like at the top of the list for
people to be thinking about but i think
anyone that's been exactly this like
trying these different diets and like
probably over
indexing on one thing versus another um
and i remember reading about this years
ago and people are like oh it's
impossible that you could eat that much
fish
like no it's not and i think there's
been a couple other famous people
um i feel like tony robbins had mercury
poisoning like there was a few other
people that have tried
like basically like leafy vegetables
like kind of these
these um pure protein diets that have
had the same problems and so i think
this is becoming i mean just like
anything else as we
as there's more demand on these products
we're we're starting to see things
uh fall apart at the seams anyway so
it's just i would i would
if you're if you're eating a lot of fish
just get tested and just have peace of
mind
yeah i'm glad you mentioned that
actually is
um andrew had high mercury as well but
no symptoms and his was actually
higher than mine which i think is even
scarier
so it must have been something we were
eating because like when you're a couple
you like eat the same things right
um or you share a lot of meals and so
that was the other thing is that
it was it was almost like a huge
blessing
that i got a symptom that was like so
unignorable that i kept like
you know fishing and asking these
questions about like what could be
giving this to me
and then i was like hey babe you should
do this too and he's like what this is
not
so anyway it's uh it's a good story wow
that's scary and did his levels go down
too and he had no symptoms
wow okay well i'm glad i know about that
now
i haven't actually like talked to
anybody who had i've talked to people
who had
um fillings that were giving them
mercury issues
but i don't think i've talked to anyone
who had mercury actually got
mercury issues from fish so that is good
to know
in my group of uh carnivore fans
yeah um okay what else do i have to ask
what kind of advice this is this is a
boring question but i like to ask it
anyway
uh what kind of advice would you give
yourself 10 years ago
oh other than don't eat a whole bunch
um like man i was always like
stressing out on all these decisions
like i was given this really good
framework
um it's a jeff bezos framework which is
like think about your life in terms of
reversible decisions and
irreversible decisions um and an
irreversible decision is like having a
kid like
that one you can't go backwards in time
but
what it makes you realize is that almost
all of your other decisions your career
decisions are like
reversible decisions and
you should actually make reversible
decisions incredibly quickly and then
just like
fix them if you made the wrong one and i
think
i spent so much time stressing about
like
the tiniest little thing like now i look
back and i like laugh i was like taking
i like always took life way too
seriously like i'm now learning to laugh
one of my goals this year is to like see
the humor in things a little bit more
it's a good year for it but it's a good
oh
was this ever the year to see the humor
in things because like things can get
dark
real quick right um and uh
i think that that would be like the
piece of advice i would tell myself is
like
michelle if it's like a if it's like a
reversible decision like just
go and do it and stop like sweating it
and like revert if it doesn't work
um and spend a bunch of time thinking
about the irreversible decisions but
i think you know i kind of stressed out
uh way too much and then this isn't
quite your question but it's related
the other piece of advice i like to give
people is
like when they're thinking of starting a
business they should just like
start now like i get so many people who
are like i've been thinking about this
for 10 years and i have
um all these ideas and i just like never
done them
and i'm like the world has changed a lot
in 10 years
um and here's the thing about like it's
kind of like the way you talk about
being a mother you're like
never ready there's never like a perfect
time to do this you just kind of like
jump in and you can learn it um
and like life takes you on that ride
like
starting a business is the exact same
way there's like no perfect time there's
no perfect market you never have enough
money and you never know enough to
really do it
but if you think about it you've got to
jump in and do it
um and that's really what makes you
successful and there's no like you
should do a little bit of research on
your competitors and have a little bit
of an idea
but basically starting is what and
iterating is what makes you successful
not like this giant brainstorming
process that people have this fictitious
idea that you need to do
that's good i like that uh okay
so i've when i was first trying to well
help my dad and kind of formulate some
sort of brand or help them with products
or whatever
i reached out to a lot of people and one
of the pieces of advice i got a lot
was focus on one thing at a time and do
it properly instead of doing
a whole bunch of things at a time and
i still kind of do a whole bunch of
things at a time
rather than focusing on one thing at a
time so what's your opinion on that like
is it
is it a better idea to do one thing at a
time or
can people manage to do a whole bunch of
them and still be successful
um i actually think this is one of the
rare things
not one of the rare things i think this
is one of the things biologically that
women are
so much better at is like balancing a
lot of
it's not multitasking that's the wrong
word it's actually balancing
so many stakeholders at once like i
think the perfect secretary of state
like is a woman because it's like how do
i balance all of these countries and all
of these different
things that are gonna happen at once so
i think about i think about instead of
one or instead of many i would actually
think about three
is really important because like even at
clear bank we have one core product
which is funding
and then we always have like experiments
in the wings that we're trying
and we're trying to almost disrupt
ourselves and see like if we can create
this next thing so like
you know we got really big with this
funding product and we were like
okay there are eventually going to be
people that um
copy us there's gonna be people that
copy us in lots of different countries
like how do we disrupt ourselves next
and so
we started working on this um really
cool product called valuation where you
could give us your data
and we could tell you how much your
company was worth which
doesn't seem like it's a big deal but
it's actually a huge deal when you go
negotiate with vcs because
as a founder you only know your
valuation like two or three times in
your career like when you go raise money
and when you sell your company
but we can actually track this within a
range for you on like a weekly basis and
then start showing you the things you
could do to like
improve that valuation and so that was a
tool that we
started working on i want to say like
eight or nine months ago and so it was
like
we still had a team working on the core
product but we had these like we call
them tiger teams
um and they're like just designed where
we try and get no one else in their way
we give them their own separate
resources they like don't have to build
into the main code base
but they basically get to be like a
little startup within the company
um and so instead of thinking about like
like and i don't know exactly what the
example is like you know
the book is amazing and the book had to
be the like flagship product but then
it's like
well let's try these like other things
and see what's working like
the thing that people underestimate in
startups is like you can now just let
the internet tell you what they like
and what they don't like and that is so
much more accurate than like
ever asking people or doing market
research because the problem with market
research has always been like
you know i always give the example it's
like how many of us wanted to like work
out this morning it's like everyone puts
up their hand in a room and then it's
like how many people actually worked out
this morning and like
17 people put up their hands it's like
that's exactly what you have been when
you ask people if they want a product
they're all like are aspirational and
they're all like yeah i would love this
um but when push comes to shove it's
like
oh people don't actually do this which
is why like kickstarter and indiegogo
were so revolutionary in the startup
space because this wasn't like
market research wasn't like do you like
my product it's like would you give me
your credit card
for something that has a 50 probability
of shipping to your house ever
and if people wanted that they were like
now we know
um that this is happening so i think
that would be the way that i would think
about it is like think about three think
about like a flagship
and then think about like i always have
like one or two experiments that i'm
trying
um that could potentially overtake uh
the main product okay i like that i like
that
answer much better than just do one
thing at a time and focus hard on it i
was like i think i can manage
i think i think that's a better rule one
and then two like
babies to see what happens with those
yeah and then as soon as you get into
like
20 like ruthless prioritization is
important right as soon as you have
10 people can't even remember 10. like
then it's just like nothing's important
anymore
um and so i think that that would be
yeah three is a good number and humans
can remember
three things really well as well which
is very helpful when you're running a
team
yeah uh okay covid this covid situation
um i'm sure there's been like e-commerce
has gone crazy right
i remember reading something that we saw
like black
friday type sales in april i don't know
where i read that or if it's accurate
but um would you what do you think
the future is going to look like for
business owners like do you think a
number of i think i know lots of people
well everyone's working from home now
do you think people are going to go back
into office buildings or
has this kind of shoved us in the
direction we were going anyway
yeah um so let's like divide up that
into kind of two
so the first is like where is ecommerce
and this one i have like a
a front row seat to what's happening in
this space so
you're right as a when you think about
um
e-commerce as a percentage of retail
sales in the first 12 weeks of covid
um we went from 14 was e-commerce
as a percent of retail sales to 28
so to put that in perspective that's
like a 10-year shift overnight we
basically went from e-commerce in 2020
to e-commerce in 2030
in 12 weeks like that's insane and what
what happened
in that it's basically we had to buy
everything online and so people
learned to buy a lot of categories
online that they no longer thought of so
like you were an early adopter to buying
food online right like you were buying
true local
but like our parents generation are like
i don't want to buy food online because
my berries are going to be crushed well
that all went out the window and they
bought you know instacart or food online
for the first time or a delivery box and
they're like
this is great i should keep doing this
um big bulky items like
patio sets and barbecue started to be
ordered online like
color cosmetics stuff that everyone i
mean no one is going to try on a color
cosmetic in a
store like i can't imagine yeah yeah
terrible thing
uh to do right now in an environment
where we have a virus
and so what happened is we broke open
all of these categories in e-commerce
where people were still really hesitant
um to buy and so i think that is a
secular trend like that one is here to
stay and
now that people have realized like how
much of their time they can get back and
how easy it is to like
return things and how like seamless this
experience can be
um i don't think we're going backwards
we will always have this concept of
showrooming which is like i want to
touch and feel something and we'll still
always have the concept of like
browsing and i'm like wandering around
in a day and i just like you know i'm
buying something i don't need like
that's not going anywhere
but like our percentage of square
footage that's retail in the us like all
of that's going to very drastically
change and we're going to kind of
right-size the
this based on um these ideas
and then okay there was that part of
your question and then there was another
part of your question i'm forgetting now
yeah i was just wondering if you think
yeah people are going to go back
into office buildings or if people are
just remote now
um so
we even internally cannot agree on this
answer so like there are so many
versions of
of what we think this answer will be
um and everyone even if you were to ask
the clearbank team would would have
totally different opinions on this
so i am a 99
extrovert like the other big five i can
kind of get like pretty close on but
like
i am at i get all of my energy from
people i
get all my best ideas with people and
like
i mean for the first like until i was 30
years old i don't think i watched a
television show by myself i just like
didn't see the point like
yeah yeah yeah i feel that yeah weird
like that is like
that is like pure so this is very
difficult for my personality type like
to not
collide with people to not have random
conversations in the office to not get
the energy and like the high fives of
being around people
is really hard but for personality types
that are
highly introverted i think this has been
like a complete godsend it's like
i have a ton of um software developers
and engineers who are at their most
productive state because
no one is bothering them right um
so here's what i think
i think that were we saw that we could
do this
because like the diet thing we were all
forced to do it there was no situation
where it's like we kind of got to come
into the office it was like we all had
to figure out how to make this work
and i think that's a really good thing i
think for parents i think for so many
groups of people
the idea that we can have some of our
teams dial in
and be just as present and not have this
idea that like
face time matters like at the end of the
day results should be the only thing
that matters
um especially in a company like it
doesn't matter how late you work
it doesn't matter like one of the things
i'm really passionate about is like i'm
a night owl and i think the world is
completely biased to warning people and
i think all the night people are like
super lazy i'm like this is the most
ridiculous thing i've ever heard
if your brain doesn't work at 6am why
are you wake up at 6am
this is so stupid um
so i just don't believe in that like
this idea of like
face time and that matters and so i
think this has
forced the world to see that people can
be really productive at home and we need
to have ways of measuring people
that are really results driven versus
like face time driven because it's just
like a cheat to be like that person's in
the office all the time they really care
it's like
that's really not true um but i do
think for
[Music]
brainstorming it's much harder when
you're not in person
um i think when you are trying to get
these like
random collisions like
i used to like bump into people at
events or like people in the industry
and it would be like oh i have this
interesting idea and you'd like kick off
a partnership and it was just very
organic
now those things are just less organic
and you have to do a little bit more
work and you have to like
i finally randomly call people now to
try and see if like
there's something we could do um
but i think so here's my guess we will
have some sort of return to
office because we cannot exist and it's
really really hard to just collaborate
and get everyone aligned
but maybe that just looks different
maybe you're bringing people together
for a week every six weeks and then you
have people that can kind of go
off and on and then i think we will
really segregate the type of jobs that
you need to be in person
for and that you can do totally remote
um
which i think is generally a really good
thing yeah yeah
i agree i had i had a hell of a time um
when i first started working
remote because i was working from home
and i'm
incredibly incredibly extroverted and i
worked at home for like three months and
i just kind of wilted
i was like why am i so sad like i'm just
sad
and so then i started i just switched to
working at a cafe which was
loud and noisy and disruptive and i was
like oh okay i can just look at people
now and i felt a lot better
so i can but then there are some like
you said some introversions like
now there aren't all these annoying
extroverts coming up and stopping me
from doing my work
so maybe giving people the option would
be good if you want to come into work
go into work but if you are productive
at home we trust you and you can work
there
yeah i totally agree with you so you
have the same like extra version
like now sometimes i just want to see
other people working it's like it's like
this weird competitive dream where it's
like if you're working i gotta work
where if i'm at home i'm like no one's
watching me i can just like go make
smoothies all day it's like
like i don't know why you're like my
brain goes there i just know
that like we have to know our own
personality traits and i can completely
agree there is something about
just being around other people working
even visually even if they're
not even if they're like on their
computer playing video games i'm like i
want to like be a part of this working
group as well
so it's really cool i would totally
describe that wilted feeling as the same
way i just felt like a lot of the
i felt a lot of my joy had been taken
out of work like i liked the
conversations i was having
i just didn't like that they were like
over
zoom all day um yeah and so just
bringing that back to like some level of
human attraction um is great
yeah everybody's waiting for that
hopefully that won't take very long to
come back
it might be a while but it might be a
while it might be a while
wow might be wow thank you very much for
coming on
that was interesting this is awesome i i
don't think i've ever gotten to cover
like
this diversity of topics in a podcast so
it was great to be here with you
uh michaela and i've been following all
the stuff and uh
and keep learning i just learned about
the snake diet um after uh after
listening to one of your podcasts so i
thought that was uh
he's funny huh yeah he was he was like
so albertan
yeah and just like kind of um
i love these anything that kind of
pushes you to think about like
things you couldn't do right like i'm
sure two years ago i was like oh there's
no way i could go 24 hours without
eating and then you get me to do it
you're like
wait people couldn't do this for seven
days i think you did a seven day fast
like that's the craziest thing
i did a 12-day fast like a month and a
half ago
it was i wouldn't like it wasn't i
wouldn't recommend it it was interesting
though and i was functional the whole
time i was like
what this isn't how i was expecting to
feel after 12 days
yeah it was intense i probably won't do
it again
but but it's like one of those things
i say that about engineering i'm like it
was a great education i would never do
that experience again but i'm happy i
did it
is that what you got your degree in yeah
yeah oh wow
that's hard that's kind of that's
yeah it was hard it was hard um and
i also just think about you know all the
the students that are going back toward
not going back like going back to school
like
i wouldn't have made it through
engineering if i wouldn't have been in
person with other people like having
people to do my assignments with it was
like
misery loves company and we were all in
this together i think there are some
types of learners that would do that but
there's going to be a huge group that
will be
left behind if we move to all digital
learning here
yeah 100 i know uh the universities i
know of anyway it's all online right now
until they're allowed to but like 2020
2021 looks like it's just gonna be
online which
yeah i mean part of university is just
the social experience
and suffering through like a chemistry
exam is way more fun with other people
than just doing it by yourself like that
sounds miserable
i know it sounds it's just it's exactly
that and you could like lament and be
like that was terrible let's grab a
drink
yeah you know get on to the next one
right but there is something that
uh you know misery loves company a
little bit if you could do it if you can
do something hard together it makes it
far more bearable
yeah so where can people find you online
oh great question so um you know at
michelle.romino michelle
um just has one ellen michelle because
my parents forgot the second l
so it's made me pretty unique but uh i'm
most active
on on instagram i do it all myself so if
you message me it's uh really me that
you're getting a response from
cool wow thanks again for coming on that
was fun
oh it's great thanks makayla
[Music]
you